From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. And to start today's program, I just have to play you a recording of this television ad from Canada, an ad so popular in Canada that people chant this ad in bars. It's made the front page of every major paper in Canada, all their nightly newscasts, the Canadian heritage minister played it for a group of Americans in Boston this week to explain Canadian cultural identity. In the ad, a young man walks onto a stage before a huge maple leaf flag, goes to a microphone, taps it meekly, and begins.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台和国际公共广播电台，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。在今天的节目开始之前，我不得不先给你们播放一段来自加拿大的电视广告录音，这段广告在加拿大非常受欢迎，以至于人们在酒吧里都会高喊其中的台词。它登上了加拿大每一份主流报纸的头版，出现在了所有的晚间新闻节目中。本周在波士顿，加拿大文化遗产部长还向一群美国人播放了这段广告，以此来解释加拿大的文化身份。在广告中，一名年轻男子走上舞台，站在一面巨大的枫叶旗前，走到麦克风前，轻轻敲了敲，然后开始说道：
Hey. I'm not a lumberjack, or a fur trader, and I don't live in an igloo or eat blubber or own a dog sled. And I don't know Jimmy, Sally, or Susie from Canada, although I'm certain they're really, really nice. I have a prime minister, not a president. I speak English and French, not American. And I pronounce it about, not aboot. I can proudly sew my country's flag on my backpack. I believe in peacekeeping, not policing, diversity, not assimilation, and that the beaver is a truly proud and noble animal. The tuque is a hat, a chesterfield is a couch, and it is pronounced zed, not zee, zed. Canada is the second largest land mass, the first nation in hockey, and the best part of North America. My name is Joe and I am Canadian.
嘿。我不是伐木工，也不是毛皮商人，我不住在冰屋里，不吃鲸脂，也没有狗拉雪橇。我不认识住在加拿大的吉米、莎莉或苏西，尽管我肯定他们真的、非常好。我有一位总理，而不是总统。我说英语和法语，不是美式英语。我把“about”读作“uh-bowt”，而不是“uh-boot”。我可以自豪地把我国的国旗缝在我的背包上。我信奉维和而非治安，信奉多样性而非同化，我认为海狸是一种真正令人自豪且高贵的动物。“Tuque”是帽子，“chesterfield”是沙发，它的发音是“zed”，而不是“zee”，是“zed”。加拿大是世界上第二大领土，是冰球运动的第一强国，是北美最棒的地方。我叫乔，我是加拿大人。
Near the end of the ad, the product flashes on screen, Molson's Beer, which in Canada is not called Molson's. It's called Canadian. Brett Marchand is vice president for marketing for Molson's Canadian, and even he is surprised at the reaction to the ad.
在广告快结束时，产品出现在屏幕上，是莫尔森啤酒（Molson's Beer），在加拿大它不叫莫尔森，而叫“加拿大”（Canadian）。布雷特·马尔尚（Brett Marchand）是莫尔森加拿大公司的营销副总裁，连他自己都对观众对这则广告的反应感到惊讶。
People are doing things like standing and cheering in theaters when it's been shown. We played it in hockey arenas, and 20,000 people have cheered like they've just won the Stanley Cup. If you've been in one of those arenas or been in a theater and seen how people generally have reacted, you can't help but think, gee, something's going on here. There is now spoofs all over the place. In fact, there was a double-page spread in one of the national newspapers yesterday that had a picture of our actor in the middle of it and written up spoofs all around him.
人们在电影院看到广告时会站起来欢呼。我们在冰球馆播放它时，两万名观众欢呼雀跃，就像刚刚赢得了斯坦利杯一样。如果你曾经身处其中一个场馆或电影院，看到人们通常的反应，你就不禁会想，天哪，这里面肯定有什么名堂。现在到处都是恶搞视频。事实上，昨天的一份全国性报纸上还有整整两个版面的报道，中间印着我们演员的照片，周围全是写的恶搞内容。
I think someone forwarded one to me, it's I am Pakistani. Hello, my mom doesn't have a dot on her forehead and my dad doesn't wear a turban. I don't live in a grass hut or eat curry every day or own a flying carpet. And I don't know Rabindra, Priya, or Akshay, though I'm sure they're very, very nice. I have a military dictator, not a prime minister. On and on and on, down to, Pakistan's the second-largest safe haven for the politically displaced, the first nation of cricket, and the most corrupt part of South Asia. My name is Khan and I am Pakistani.
我想有人转发给我过一个，叫“我是巴基斯坦人”。你好，我妈额头上没有红点，我爸也不裹头巾。我不住在草屋里，不天天吃咖喱，也没有飞毯。我不认识拉宾德拉、普里亚或阿克沙伊，尽管我肯定他们也非常、非常好。我有一位军事独裁者，而不是总理。就这样一直说下去，直到最后，巴基斯坦是政治流离失所者的第二大避风港，是板球的第一强国，是南亚最腐败的地方。我叫汗，我是巴基斯坦人。
Of course, every ethnic group in Canada is weighing in with its own version of the ad. People feel misunderstood, people feel overlooked, and to have a call to arms that, on the one hand, gives you the thrill of being in a cheering mob yelling we are number one, while, on the other hand, is simply just kind of a joke, that is a very appealing package. You get the pleasure of being in a mob without the threat of mob violence, of rising totalitarianism, of rampaging and rioting. There is a deep part of most of us that takes pleasure in being in a crowd, a real crowd, I mean. A mass of people that is thinking and feeling the same thing at the same time, jumping to its feet as one unit, yelling for a cause, or a team, or a band, or whatever. Today on our program, the pleasure of being in a mob, the terror of being in a mob altogether.
当然，加拿大的每一个少数族裔都在发表他们自己版本的广告。人们感到被误解，感到被忽视，而拥有这样一个号召力，一方面能给你一种置身于大声高呼“我们是第一”的欢呼人群中的快感，另一方面又仅仅是一个笑话，这确实是一个非常有吸引力的组合。你既能享受到置身于人群中的快乐，又没有受到暴民暴力、极权主义抬头、暴乱和骚乱的威胁。我们大多数人内心深处都有这样一种渴望，想要置身于人群之中，我是说真正的人群中。一群人在同一时间思考和感受着同样的事情，作为一个整体一跃而起，为某种事业、某个团队、某个乐队或任何事物大声呐喊。今天我们的节目主题就是：置身于暴民中的快乐，以及置身于暴民中的恐惧。
Our program today in three acts. Act One, Among the Thugs. Bill Buford joins a mob as it riots, and he writes, I felt weightless. I felt nothing would happen to me, I felt anything might happen to me. Act Two, One Tin Soldier Rides Away. What happens when a teacher in a small town in Connecticut turns a class of seventh graders into an angry mob on the rampage? Act Three, The Hissing of Winter Lawns, in which Alix Spiegel explains how a 21st century mob may be different than its predecessors. Stay with us.
今天的节目分为三幕。第一幕，《暴徒之中》。比尔·布福德（Bill Buford）加入了一个骚乱的暴徒群体，他写道：我感到身体轻盈。我觉得什么都不会发生在我身上，我又觉得什么都可能发生在我身上。第二幕，《锡兵远去》。当康涅狄格州一个小镇的老师把一群七年级的学生变成一群愤怒的暴民时，会发生什么？第三幕，《冬日草坪的嘶嘶声》，阿利克斯·斯皮格尔（Alix Spiegel）将解释21世纪的暴民与前人有何不同。请继续收听。
Act One. In 1984, Bill Buford set out to try to understand the soccer hooligans who were rioting in ways large and small on a regular basis after soccer matches in England. He drank with them, went to matches with them, got to know them, and his account of his time with them, called Among the Thugs , is this remarkable document. As Buford points out, since ancient times many people have written about the behavior of mobs, but they were almost always outsiders, frightened observers standing outside the action. Few people have written from the perspective of someone caught up in the violence. And by the time he is done, you understand that the thrill of being in a rampaging mob is as hardwired into us, as basic to us as a species, as the ability to love.
第一幕。1984年，比尔·布福德着手试图了解英国足球比赛后定期进行大规模和小规模骚乱的足球流氓。他和他们一起喝酒，一起去看比赛，结识了他们。他记录这段时光的书《暴徒之中》，是一份非凡的文献。正如布福德所指出的，自古以来，许多人写过暴民的行为，但他们几乎总是局外人，是站在行动之外的恐惧观察者。很少有人从身陷暴力事件的人的角度进行描写。而当他写完时，你会明白，置身于狂暴的暴民之中的快感，就像人类爱人的能力一样，是我们物种与生俱来的基本特质。
Bill Buford agreed to come onto our program and read an excerpt from his book, a scene in which he goes with 257 fans of the soccer team Manchester United on a trip to Italy to see their team play. There is a phenomenal amount of drinking. Some supporters are arrested. On the buses to the stadium, they urinate out the windows, they moon the Italians, they scream obscenities at the Italians, they threw bottles at the Italians. And finally, an Italian boy responds a way that I think many people would after this kind of assault. He answers in kind. He throws a stone back, one stone.
比尔·布福德同意来到我们的节目，朗读他书中的一个片段。那是他与257名曼联足球队的球迷一起前往意大利观看球队比赛的场景。期间有惊人的饮酒量。一些支持者被逮捕。在去体育场的巴士上，他们从窗户向外小便，向意大利人展示屁股，对意大利人大喊淫秽语言，向意大利人扔瓶子。最终，一个意大利男孩做出了我认为许多人在这种攻击之后都会做出的反应。他以牙还牙。他扔回了一块石头，仅仅是一块石头。
The effect on those inside the bus was immediate. To be, suddenly, the target came as a terrible shock. The incredulity was immense. Those bastards, one of the supporters exclaimed, are throwing stones at the windows. And the look on his face conveyed such urgent dismay that you could only agree that a stone-throwing Italian was a very bad person, indeed. The presumption-- after all, a window could get broken, and someone might get hurt-- was deeply offensive.
这对车里的人产生了直接的影响。突然成为目标让人感到极大的震惊。那种不信任感极其强烈。其中一个支持者惊呼道：“那些混蛋正在向窗户扔石头。”他脸上的表情流露出一种迫切的沮丧，你不得不赞同，一个扔石头的意大利人确实是个坏人。这种假设——毕竟，窗户可能会被打破，某人可能会受伤——是极具冒犯性的。
And everyone became very, very angry. Looking around me, I realized that I was no longer surrounded by raving, hysterically nationalistic social deviants. I was now surrounded by raving, hysterically nationalistic social deviants in a frenzy. And anything that came to hand-- bottles, jars of peanuts, fruit, cartons of juice, anything-- was summarily hurled through the windows. Those bastards, the lad next to me said, teeth clenched, lobbing an unopened beer can at a cluster of elderly men in dark jackets. Those bastards.
每个人都变得非常、非常生气。环顾四周，我意识到我不再被一群狂热的、歇斯底里的民族主义社会偏差者所包围。我现在被一群陷入疯狂的、歇斯底里的民族主义社会偏差者所包围。任何手头的东西——瓶子、花生罐、水果、果汁盒，任何东西——都被迅速扔出了窗外。我旁边的那个小伙子咬牙切齿地说：“那些混蛋”，并将一罐未开封的啤酒扔向一群身穿深色夹克的老年人。“那些混蛋。”
When the buses of the United supporters pulled into the cool evening shadow cast by the Stadio Comunale, a large crowd was already there waiting for the English. Somehow the match started, was played, ended. And while it could be said that there was no single serious incident, it could also be said that there was no moment without one. Things were coming at us from the air. Not just bottles and pieces of fruit, but also long sticks, the staff of the event's flags, firecrackers, and smoke bombs. Several people were hurt, and one supporter was taken away to the hospital.
当曼联支持者的巴士驶入市政体育场（Stadio Comunale）投下的清凉傍晚阴影中时，一大群人已经在那里等着英国人了。比赛不知怎么就开始了，进行了，也结束了。虽然可以说没有发生单一的严重事件，但也可以说没有哪一刻是平安无事的。东西不断从空中飞向我们。不仅是瓶子和水果，还有长棍、旗杆、鞭炮和烟雾弹。有几个人受伤了，一名支持者被送往医院。
And then when the match ended, everything started moving at great speed. Everything would continue to move at great speed for many hours. I remember that riot police started kicking one of the supporters who had fallen down. I remember hearing that Sammy had arrived and then coming upon him. He was big, well-dressed with heavy, horn-rimmed glasses that made him look like a physics student, standing underneath the bleachers, his back to the match, an expensive leather bag and a camera hanging over his shoulder, having just come from France by taxi. I remember some screaming. There had been a stabbing, I didn't see it. And with the screaming, everyone bolted, animal speed, instinct speed, and pushed past the police and rushed for the exit. But the gate into the tunnel was locked and the United supporters slammed into it. It was impossible to get out.
当比赛结束时，一切都以极快的速度开始移动。一切在接下来的许多小时里都保持着极快的速度。我记得防暴警察开始踢一名跌倒的支持者。我记得听说萨米（Sammy）到了，然后碰到了他。他身材高大，衣着考究，戴着一副让他看起来像物理系学生的厚重黑框眼镜，站在看台下，背对着比赛现场，肩上挎着一个昂贵的皮包和一台相机，他刚从法国乘出租车过来。我记得有尖叫声。有人被捅伤了，我没看见。随着尖叫声，每个人都逃跑了，带着动物般的本能速度，挤过警察，涌向出口。但通往隧道的门被锁上了，曼联的支持者们撞了上去。根本无法出去。
Throughout this last period of the match, I had been hearing a new phrase. It's going to go off. It's going to go off, someone said, and his eyes were glassy as though he'd taken a drug. If this keeps up, I heard another say, then it's going to go off. And the phrase recurred. It's going to go off, it's going to go off, spoken softly. But each time it was repeated, it gained authority. Everyone was pressed against the locked gate and the police arrived moments later. The police pulled and pushed in one direction and supporters pushed in another, wanting to get out. It was shove and counter-shove. It was crushing, uncomfortable. The supporters were humorless and determined. It's going to go off. People were whispering. I heard, watch out for knives. Zip up your coat. I heard, fill up your pockets. I heard, it's going to go off. Stay together. It's going to go off.
在比赛的最后阶段，我一直听到一个新短语。“要爆发了。要爆发了，”有人说，他的眼睛看起来像吸了毒一样呆滞。另一个人说：“如果这种情况持续下去，那么它就要爆发了。”这个短语反复出现。“要爆发了，要爆发了，”有人轻声说道。但每一次重复，它似乎就多了一分权威。每个人都挤在锁着的门上，警察几分钟后赶到。警察向一个方向推挤，支持者向另一个方向推挤，想要出去。这是推搡与反推搡。那种感觉令人窒息、极不舒服。支持者们毫无幽默感且态度坚决。“要爆发了。”人们在耳语。我听到：“小心刀子。拉好你的外套。”我听到：“把口袋填满。”我听到：“要爆发了。聚在一起。要爆发了。”
I was growing nervous and slipped my notebook into my shirt up against my chest and buttoned up my jacket. A chant had started. United, United, United. The chant was clipped and sure. United, United, United. The word was repeated, United. And through the repetition, its meaning started to change, pertaining less to a sporting event or a football club and sounding, instead, like a chance of unity, something political. It had become the chance of a mob. United, United, United, United. And then it stopped. The gate had been opened and the English supporters surged forwards. And when they emerged, they came out very fast with police trailing behind, trying to keep up. They came as a mob with everyone pressed together, hands on the shoulders of the person in front, moving quickly, almost at a sprint, racing down the line of police-- helmet and shields and truncheons-- a peripheral blur.
我开始感到紧张，把笔记本塞进衬衫里紧贴胸口，扣好外套。一阵口号声开始了。“联队，联队，联队。”这口号声短促而坚定。“联队，联队，联队。”这个词被重复着，“联队”。通过重复，它的含义开始改变，不再仅仅是指体育赛事或足球俱乐部，听起来更像是一种团结的呼喊，像是一种政治诉求。它变成了暴民的口号。“联队，联队，联队，联队。”然后它停止了。门开了，英国支持者涌了出来。当他们出来时，他们跑得非常快，警察在后面紧追不舍，试图跟上。他们像一群暴徒，每个人紧紧挤在一起，手搭在前面人的肩膀上，快速移动，几乎是在短跑，沿着警察的防线——头盔、盾牌和警棍——飞奔而过，周围一片模糊。
The line of police led to the buses. But just before the bus door, someone in front veered sharply and the mob followed. The police had anticipated this and were waiting. The group turned again, veering in another direction and rushed out into the space between the two buses. It came to a sudden stop. And I slammed into the person in front of me, and people slammed into me from behind. The police had been there as well. There were about 200 people crushed together, but they seemed able to move in unison like some giant, strangely coordinated insect. A third direction was tried. The police were not there. There were no police anywhere.
警察的防线通向巴士。但就在到达车门前，前面有人猛地转弯，暴民也随之转向。警察预料到了这一点，已经在那里等着了。人群再次转弯，向另一个方向冲去，冲入两辆巴士之间的空隙。它突然停了下来。我撞在了前面的人身上，后面的人也撞在我身上。警察也在那里。大约有200人挤在一起，但他们似乎能够像某种巨大且协调奇怪的昆虫一样一致移动。他们尝试了第三个方向。那里没有警察。到处都没有警察。
What was the duration of what followed? It might have been 20 minutes. It seemed longer. It was windy and dark and the trees, blowing back and forth in front of the street lamps, cast long, moving shadows. I was never able to see clearly. I knew to follow Sammy. The moment the group broke free, he had handed his bag and camera to someone, telling them to give them back later at the hotel. Then Sammy turned and started running backwards. He appeared to be measuring the group, taking in its size. The energy, he said, still running backwards, speaking to no one in particular, the energy is very high.
随后发生的事情持续了多久？可能持续了20分钟。感觉时间更长。风很大，天很黑，在路灯前摇曳的树木投下长长、移动的阴影。我从来无法看清楚。我知道要跟着萨米。人群冲破包围的那一刻，他把包和相机交给了某人，告诉他们稍后在酒店还给他。然后萨米转过身，开始倒着跑。他似乎在评估人群，观察它的人数。“能量，”他还在倒着跑，不是对任何人说，而是自言自语，“能量非常高。”
He was alert, vital, moving constantly, looking in all directions. He was holding out his hands with this fingers outstretched. Feel the energy, he said. There were six or seven younger supporters jogging beside him. And it would be some time before I realized that there were always six or seven younger supporters jogging beside him. When he turned in one direction, they turned with him. When he ran backwards, they ran backwards. No doubt if Sammy had suddenly become airborne, there would have been six or seven younger supporters desperately flapping their arms trying to do the same.
他很机警，充满活力，不断走动，环顾四周。他伸出双手，手指张开。“感受这种能量，”他说。有六七个年轻的支持者在他身边慢跑。过了好一会儿我才意识到，他身边总有那六七个年轻的支持者。当他转向一个方向时，他们也跟着他转。当他倒着跑时，他们也倒着跑。毫无疑问，如果萨米突然飞到空中，那六七个年轻支持者也会绝望地挥舞着手臂，试图做同样的事情。
The younger supporters were in fact very young. At first, I put their age at around 16. But they might have been younger. They might have been 14. They might have been nine. I take pleasure even now in thinking of them as nothing more than overgrown nine-year-olds. They were nasty little nine year olds, who, in some kind of prepubescent confusion, regarded Sammy as their dad.
那些年轻的支持者事实上非常年轻。起初，我以为他们大概16岁左右。但他们可能更小。可能是14岁。甚至可能是9岁。即使现在，一想到他们不过是些长大了的九岁小孩，我就觉得好笑。他们是些讨厌的九岁小孩，在某种青春期前的困惑中，把萨米当作了他们的父亲。
At one moment, a cluster of police came rushing towards us. And Sammy, having spotted them, whispered a new command, hissing that we were to disperse. The members of the group split up, some crossing the street, some carrying on down the center, but some falling behind, until they'd got past the policeman whereupon Sammy turned around, running backwards again, and ordered everyone to regroup. And the little ones, like trained dogs, herded the members of the group back together.
有一刻，一群警察冲向我们。萨米发现了他们，低声发出一个新的命令，嘶嘶地说我们要分散。小组成员分开了，有的穿过街道，有的沿着中间继续走，但有的落在后面，直到他们越过警察，萨米又转过身，再次倒着跑，命令大家重新集结。那些小家伙就像训练有素的狗一样，把小组成员赶回到了一起。
I trotted along. Everyone was moving at such a speed that, to ensure I didn't miss anything, I concentrated on keeping up with Sammy. I could see that this was starting to irritate him. He kept having to notice me. What are you doing here, he asked me, after he had turned around running backwards, doing a quick head count after everyone had regrouped. He knew precisely what I was doing there. And he had made a point of asking his question loudly enough that the others had to hear it as well.
我小跑着跟上。每个人移动的速度都非常快，为了确保我不会错过任何事情，我专注于紧跟萨米。我能看出这开始让他恼火。他不得不注意到我。“你在这里干什么？”在重新集结后，他倒着跑转过身，快速清点人数时问我。他清楚地知道我在那里干什么。而且他特意大声地问这个问题，好让其他人也能听到。
Just the thing, I thought. [BLEEP] off, one of his runts said suddenly, peering into my face. He had a knife. I dropped back a bit, just outside of striking range. I looked about me. I didn't recognize anyone. I was surrounded by people I hadn't met. Worse, I was surrounded by people I hadn't met who kept telling me to [BLEEP] off. Nobody was saying a word. There was a muted grunting and the sound of their feet on the pavement. And every now and then, Sammy would whisper one of his commands. I remember thinking in the clearest possible terms, I don't want to get beaten up.
“真倒霉，”我想。他手下的一个矮子突然瞪着我的脸说：“滚开。”他带着一把刀。我退后了一点，刚好在攻击范围之外。我环顾四周。我不认识任何人。我被一群我不认识的人包围了。更糟糕的是，我被一群我没见过且一直叫我“滚开”的人包围了。没有人说话。只有低沉的咕哝声和他们踩在人行道上的声音。每隔一会儿，萨米就会低声下达他的命令。我记得当时最明确的想法是：我不想被揍。
And then Sammy, having judged the moment to be right, suddenly stopped. And abandoning all pretense of invisibility, he shouted, stop. Everyone stopped. Turn. Everyone turned. They knew what to expect. I didn't. It was only then that I saw the Italians, who had been following us. In the half-light, streetlight darkness, I couldn't tell how many there were, but there were enough for me to realize-- holy [BLEEP]-- that I was now unexpectedly in the middle of a very big fight. Having dropped back to get out of the reach of Sammy and his lieutenants, I was in the rear, which as the group turned, had suddenly become the front.
然后萨米判断时机已到，突然停了下来。他不再伪装隐身，大喊一声：“停。”每个人都停了下来。“转身。”每个人都转了过去。他们知道会发生什么。我不知道。直到那时，我才看到一直跟着我们的意大利人。在半明半暗的街灯下，我看不出有多少人，但人数足以让我意识到——天哪——我竟然意外地处于一场大规模斗殴的中心。为了躲开萨米和他的副手，我退到了后面，而当队伍一转身，我突然变成了先锋。
Adrenaline is one of the body's more powerful chemicals. Seeing the English on one side of me and the Italians on the other, I remember seeming quickly to take on the properties of a small helicopter, rising several feet in the air and moving out of everybody's way. There was a roar, everybody roaring, and the English supporters charged into the Italians. In the next second, I went down. A dark blur and then smack. I got hit on the side of the head by a beer can, a full one, thrown powerfully enough to knock me over.
肾上腺素是人体内威力最强的化学物质之一。看着英国人站在我的一边，意大利人站在另一边，我记得自己似乎很快就具备了小型直升机的特性，升高了几英尺，避开了所有人的攻击。一声咆哮，所有人都在咆哮，英国支持者冲向意大利人。下一秒，我就倒下了。一片黑暗，然后是猛地一下。我的头部侧面被一个啤酒罐砸中，是满满的一罐，力道大到把我掀翻在地。
As I got up, two policemen, the only two I saw, came rushing past. And one of them clubbed me on the back of the head. Back down I went.
当我站起来时，两名警察——我看到的仅有的两名警察——冲了过来。其中一人用警棍打在我的后脑勺上。我又倒了下去。
Directly in front of me, so close I could almost reach out to touch his face, a young Italian-- a boy, really-- had been knocked down. As he was getting up, an England supporter pushed the boy down again, ramming his flat hand against the boy's face. He fell back and his head hit the pavement, the back of it bouncing slightly. Two of the Manchester United supporters appeared. One kicked the boy in the ribs. It was a soft sound, which surprised me. You could hear the impact of the shoe on the fabric of the boy's clothing. He was kicked again, this time very hard, and the sound was still soft. Muted. The boy reached down to protect himself, to guard his ribs, and the other English supporters then kicked him in the face.
就在我面前，近得我几乎可以伸手触碰到他的脸，一个年轻的意大利人——其实是个男孩——被打倒了。当他正要站起来时，一个英格兰支持者再次把他推倒，手掌猛地拍在他的脸上。他向后倒去，后脑勺撞在人行道上，稍微弹了一下。两个曼联的支持者出现了。其中一个踢了男孩的肋骨。那是沉闷的一声，这让我感到惊讶。你可以听到鞋子撞击男孩衣服布料的声音。他又被踢了一脚，这次非常用力，声音依然沉闷。是那种被压制的声音。男孩伸手保护自己，护住肋骨，另一名英国支持者随后踢了他的脸。
This was a soft sound as well, but it was different. You could tell that it was his face that had been kicked and not his body, and not something protected by clothing. It sounded gritty.
这也是一声沉闷的响声，但却不同。你能听出被踢的是他的脸，而不是他的身体，也不是被衣物保护的地方。听起来沙沙作响。
Another Manchester United supporter appeared, and another, and then a third. There were now six, and they all started kicking the boy on the ground. The boy covered his face. I was transfixed. It was as if time had dramatically slowed down and each second had a distinct beginning and end, like a sequence of images on a roll of film. Two more Manchester United supporters appeared. There was no speech, only that soft, yielding sound. Although sometimes it was a gravelly, scraping one, of the blows, one after the other. The thought of it, eight people kicking the boy at once. At what point is the job completed?
又出现了一个曼联支持者，接着又一个，然后是第三个。现在有六个人了，他们开始一起踢地上的男孩。男孩护住脸。我惊呆了。时间仿佛极其缓慢地放慢了脚步，每一秒都有明显的开始和结束，就像胶卷上的一连串图像。又有两名曼联支持者出现。没有人说话，只有那沉闷、充满弹性的声音。尽管有时是那种粗糙的、摩擦的声音，那是打击的声音，一下接一下。想到有八个人同时在踢这个男孩。什么时候才算踢完了呢？
A policeman appeared, but only one. Where were the other police? There had been so many before. The policeman came running hard and knocked over two of the supporters. And the others fled. And then time accelerated. No longer slow motion time, but time moving very fast. We ran off. I don't know what happened to the boy. I then noticed that all around me, there were others like him, others who had been tripped up and had their faces kicked. I had to sidestep a body on the ground to avoid running on top of it. In the vernacular of the supporters, it had now gone off. With that first violent exchange, some kind of threshold had been crossed, some notional boundary. On one side of that boundary had been a sense of limits, an ordinary understanding, even among this lot, of what you didn't do. We were now someplace where there would be few limits, where the sense that there were things you didn't do had ceased to exist. It became very violent.
一名警察出现了，但只有一名。其他警察都在哪儿？之前明明有那么多。警察猛地冲过来，撞倒了两名支持者。其余的人逃走了。然后时间加速了。不再是慢镜头，而是时间飞快地流逝。我们跑开了。我不知道那个男孩怎么样了。我随后注意到，在我周围，有其他和他一样的人，那些被绊倒并被踢中脸部的人。我不得不避开地上的身体，以免踩到他们。用支持者的行话来说，现在“爆发了”。随着那第一次激烈的交锋，某种门槛被跨过了，某种观念上的边界。在那条边界的一边，曾存在着一种克制感，一种平常的理解，即使是在这群人中，也知道什么是不能做的。我们现在身处一个几乎没有限制的地方，那个“有些事情不该做”的概念已经不复存在了。这变得非常暴力。
I caught up with Sammy. Sammy was transported. He was snapping his fingers and jogging in place, his legs pumping up and down, and he was repeating the phrase, it's going off, it's going off. Everyone around him was excited. It was an excitement that verged on something greater, an emotion more transcendent. Joy at the very least, but more like ecstasy. There was an intense energy about it. It was impossible not to feel some of the thrill. Somebody near me said that he was happy. He said that he was very, very happy, that he could not remember ever being so happy. And I looked hard at him, wanting to memorize his face so that I might find him later and ask him what it was that made for this happiness, what it was like. It was a strange thought. Here was someone who believed that at this precise moment following a street scuffle, he had succeeded in capturing one of life's most elusive qualities. But then he, dazed, babbling away about his happiness, disappeared into the crowd and the darkness.
我赶上了萨米。萨米进入了一种狂喜状态。他打着响指，在原地慢跑，双腿上下抽动，他反复念叨着那句话：“要爆发了，要爆发了。”他周围的每个人都很兴奋。那是一种近乎超越性的情感，一种狂喜。这其中蕴含着一种强烈的能量。不可能不感受到其中的快感。我旁边的人说他很快乐。他说他非常、非常快乐，他记不得自己曾经有过这么快乐。我紧紧盯着他，想记住他的脸，以便以后找到他，问他是什么让他感到这种快乐，那是什么样的感觉。这真是一个奇怪的想法。在这里，在街头斗殴之后这一刻，有人相信他已经成功捕捉到了生活中最难以捉摸的特质之一。但随后，他神志恍惚，对着自己的快乐喋喋不休，消失在人群和黑暗中。
The group crossed a street, a major intersection. At the head of the traffic was a bus. And one of the supporters stepped up to the front of it and, from about six feet, hurled something with great force-- it wasn't a stone. It was big and made of metal, like the manifold of a car engine-- straight into the driver's windshield. The sound of that shattering windshield, I realize now, was a powerful stimulant, physical and intrusive. Crossing this intersection, traffic coming from four directions, supporters trotting on top of cars, the sound of this thing going through the windshield, the crash following its impact had the effect of increasing the heat of the feeling. I can't describe it any other way. It was almost literally a matter of temperature.
队伍穿过了一条街道，一个主要十字路口。车流的最前面是一辆巴士。其中一名支持者走上前，从大约六英尺远的地方，用力投掷了某种东西——那不是石头。那东西很大，是金属做的，像汽车引擎的歧管——直直地砸进了司机的挡风玻璃。我现在意识到，那挡风玻璃碎裂的声音是一种强大的兴奋剂，既是生理上的，也是侵入性的。穿过这个十字路口，车流从四个方向涌来，支持者们在汽车顶上小跑，挡风玻璃被砸穿的声音，随后撞击产生的巨响，产生了让那种感觉升温的效果。我无法用其他方式描述它。这几乎在字面上关乎温度。
We moved on. A bin was thrown through a car showroom window. There was another loud crashing sound, a shop, its door was smashed. A clothing shop, its windows were smashed, and one or two English supporters lingered to loot from the display. The city is ours, Sammy said. And he repeated the possessive each time with greater intensity. It is ours. Ours. Ours.
我们继续前进。一个垃圾桶被扔进了一家汽车陈列室的窗户。又是另一声巨大的破碎声，一家商店的门被砸碎了。一家服装店，它的窗户被砸烂了，一两个英国支持者滞留在那儿，从展示柜里掠夺财物。萨米说：“这座城市是我们的。”他每次重复这个所有格代词时，语气都更强烈。它是我们的。我们的。我们的。
What happens when a crowd goes over the edge or the cliff? The metaphors, though hackneyed, are revealing. This is the way they talk about it. They talk about the crack, the buzz, and the fix. They talk about having to have it, of being unable to forget it when they do, of not wanting to forget it ever. They talk about being sustained by it, telling and retelling what happened and what it felt like. They talk about it with the pride of the privileged of those who have had, seen, felt, been through something that other people have not.
当一群人越过边缘或悬崖时会发生什么？这些比喻虽然陈词滥调，但却揭示了真相。这就是他们谈论这件事的方式。他们谈论那种快感、刺激和瘾头。他们谈论那种必须得到它的感觉，谈论一旦尝试就无法忘记它，谈论根本不想忘记它的愿望。他们谈论它时充满了特权者的自豪感，因为他们经历、见过、感受过别人没有经历过的事情。
Violence is one of the most intensely lived experiences, and for those capable of giving themselves over to it, it's one of the most intense pleasures. I felt, as the group passed over its metaphorical cliff, that I had literally become weightless. I had abandoned gravity, was greater than it. I felt myself to be hovering above myself, capable of perceiving everything in slow motion, and in overwhelming detail. And for the first time, I'm able to understand the words they use to describe it. That crowd violence was their drug. What was it like for me? An experience of absolute completeness.
暴力是最强烈的生活体验之一，对于那些能够沉溺于其中的人来说，它是最强烈的快感之一。当队伍越过那道隐喻的悬崖时，我感到自己真的变得轻盈了。我摆脱了重力，变得比重力更强大。我感到自己悬浮在自己身体之上，能够以慢动作感知一切，并能感知到极其详尽的细节。我第一次能够理解他们用来形容这种感觉的词语。那种群体暴力就是他们的毒品。对我来说那是什么感觉？一种绝对完整的体验。
Bill Buford reading from his book Among the Thugs . He is the literary and fiction editor at The New Yorker magazine. Coming up, class warfare seventh grade-style. That is, when seventh graders become an angry mob. That and more in a minute, from Public Radio International, when our program continues.
刚才朗读的是比尔·布福德的书《暴徒之中》。他是《纽约客》杂志的文学和小说编辑。接下来，七年级的班级战争。也就是说，当七年级学生变成一群愤怒的暴民时。这一切以及更多内容，一分钟后，当我们的节目继续时，来自国际公共广播电台。
[MUSIC - "MAIN TITLE (THE GODFATHER WALTZ)," NINO ROTA]
[音乐 - “片头主题曲（教父圆舞曲）”，尼诺·罗塔]
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, the pleasure of being in a mob and the terror of being in a mob. We have arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, One Tin Soldier Rides Away. We tend to believe that it's other people who will be susceptible to the lure of the mob, not ourselves. Karen Bernstein doesn't feel that way because of something that happened to her in the seventh grade in rural Connecticut. It's the incident she remembers more than anything else that happened that year in school. 26 years later at her class reunion, this incident sparked the most animated conversations. So she went back and interviewed her former classmates and her teacher.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们的节目都会选择一个主题，为您带来各种关于该主题的故事。今天的节目主题是：置身于暴民中的快乐与置身于暴民中的恐惧。我们进入了节目的第二幕。第二幕，《锡兵远去》。我们倾向于相信，是别人更容易受到暴民诱惑的影响，而不是我们自己。凯伦·伯恩斯坦（Karen Bernstein）却不这么认为，因为她在康涅狄格州乡村读七年级时发生过一件事。这是她记忆中那一年学校里发生的比任何事都深刻的事情。26年后在同学聚会上，这件事引发了最热烈的讨论。于是她回去采访了她曾经的同学和老师。
I have before me a Xerox of a teacher's private lesson plan. It's dated September 24, 1973. It's handwritten in the neat, cursive script if my seventh grade social studies teacher, Mr. Les Levitt. It's titled, Course on Totalitarianism. It reads, objective, I want the students to realize how a person or a small group of people can hypnotize a large group of people into following them. Rather than run away from the fear and danger, I want the students to experience all of the emotion, fear and terror firsthand. By providing such a learning experience, I hope to provide the students with enough information to avoid such a situation in the future. Method for achieving objective, a simulation of a totalitarian takeover as a class project.
我面前有一份老师的私人教案复印件。日期是1973年9月24日。它是由我的七年级社会研究老师莱斯·莱维特（Les Levitt）先生用工整的草书手写的。标题是《极权主义课程》。内容如下：“目标：我希望学生们意识到一个人或一小群人是如何催眠一大群人去追随他们的。我不想让他们逃避恐惧和危险，而是希望学生们亲身体验所有的情感、恐惧和恐怖。通过提供这样的学习体验，我希望提供给学生足够的信息，以避免未来发生类似的情况。达成目标的方法：作为班级项目，模拟一场极权主义的夺权行动。”
Mr. Levitt was the most popular teacher at Shepaug Middle School where this all happened, probably the youngest. He was hip, perhaps a little on the hippie side. He had long sideburns and wore aviator glasses and bell bottoms. And we loved him. One day in class, he told us we had rights, that we should have a voice in how the school was run, that we could eat without a lunchroom matron telling us where to sit. When I tracked him down, Mr. Levitt remembered it this way.
莱维特先生是谢珀格中学（Shepaug Middle School）最受欢迎的老师，可能也是最年轻的。他很时髦，甚至有点嬉皮士的味道。他留着长长的鬓角，戴着飞行员眼镜，穿着喇叭裤。我们都很爱他。有一天在课堂上，他告诉我们拥有权利，我们应该对学校的管理方式有发言权，我们可以吃午饭，不用午餐女主管告诉我们要坐在哪里。当我找到他时，莱维特先生是这样回忆的：
I had planned to do something nice and easy, maybe a couple of days or a week. I started on the project and started to get them into kind of a rebellious mood. And I said, maybe what we ought to do is we ought to be able to write a bill of rights or something like that for students. And then I remember telling them a little bit about protesting Vietnam. And they said, were you one of those protesters, Mr. Levitt? I said, yeah, I was protesting. Oh yeah, I wore the armbands and everything.
我本来计划做点轻松愉快的事，也许几天或一周。我开始了这个项目，并开始让他们进入一种反叛的情绪。我说，也许我们应该做的是，我们应该能够为学生写一部权利法案之类的东西。然后我记得告诉了他们一点关于抗议越战的事。他们说：“莱维特先生，你是那些抗议者之一吗？”我说：“是的，我在抗议。噢，是的，我戴了袖标等等。”
I'll never forget it. I was standing there and I was just looking at them, and they were just so attentive. And it just came upon me like, wow. I could really do something here, because everybody is so into it. Why not carry it a step further? So with Mr. Levitt, we made armbands. We also created a flag, like the flag from the movie Billy Jack . Then the school administrators commenced a series of repressive actions, all designed to rile us up.
我永远不会忘记。我站在那里，看着他们，他们是那么专注。这让我产生了一种感觉，哇。我真的可以在这里做些什么，因为每个人都这么投入。为什么不更进一步呢？于是，在莱维特先生的带领下，我们做了袖标。我们还制作了一面旗帜，就像电影《比利·杰克》（Billy Jack）里的旗帜一样。然后，学校行政人员开始了一系列压制行动，所有这些都是为了激怒我们。
The head of the social studies department banned the flag and the armbands in a bluntly worded edict, demanding their immediate destruction. We countered by sending a letter to the principal demanding that he allow our new armbands in school.
社会研究系主任发布了一项措辞严厉的法令，禁止使用旗帜和袖标，要求立即销毁它们。我们通过给校长发信进行回击，要求他允许我们在学校里佩戴新袖标。
And I remember going into the classroom and having Les Levitt start chanting whatever it was that we were, some power chant.
我记得走进教室，听着莱斯·莱维特开始喊出不论那是什么的口号，某种权力口号。
He got up on the end of the desks and walked around the desks on top of the desks. And he stopped in front of me. He bent down. And he said, do you think that my walking on the desks is strange?
他爬上课桌的尽头，在课桌顶上走来走去。他在我面前停了下来。他弯下腰。他说：“你觉得我在课桌上走奇怪吗？”
Let me read to you for a second from a letter that you signed around September 27 or so, so three or four days into the experiment itself. I guess we're demanding, at this point, that armbands be allowed worn and that flags go up. And at one point, you say, regarding tradition, the flag and the armbands are our tradition. We are exercising our rights under the Declaration of Independence. We suggest you read the document, especially the second paragraph.
让我读一下你大约在9月27日左右，也就是实验开始后的三四天签署的一封信。我想此时我们是在要求允许佩戴袖标和升起旗帜。在某一点上，你说道：“关于传统，旗帜和袖标就是我们的传统。我们正在行使《独立宣言》赋予我们的权利。我们建议你阅读这份文件，特别是第二段。”
Which meant we would have had to have read it in order to cite it.
这意味着我们得先读过它才能引用它。
The principal wrote us back saying, regarding tradition, you are on pretty shaky ground on this point. Whoever heard of a two week old tradition? But who am I to quibble? Go, go and fly your ugly flag. And how about an appropriate song to go with your flag? My title suggestion? "It's a Grand Old Rag."
校长回信说：“关于传统，你在这一点上基础相当薄弱。谁听说过两周大的传统？但我又何必吹毛求疵呢？去吧，去飞你们那面丑陋的旗帜吧。还有，给你们的旗帜配上一首合适的歌怎么样？我的标题建议是《那是一首伟大的老曲子》（It's a Grand Old Rag）。”
So he's responding back by playing the bad guy, reinforcing the enemy.
所以他通过扮演反派角色来回应，加强了敌人的形象。
And what was our reaction?
我们的反应是什么？
Oh, you were livid. I mean, you were livid. And the more we drew you into this, the more you lost sight of what was going on around you.
噢，你们当时暴跳如雷。我的意思是，你们简直怒不可遏。我们把你拉进来越深，你就越看不清周围正在发生什么。
We were at war. And Mr. Levitt organized the class into a strict military hierarchy. A few of the most popular and well-adjusted kids were tapped to be members of the elite inner council. Others were freedom police, some were runners for the inner council. Mr. Levitt became General Levitt. He created intricate wall charts listing each student's rank and duties. We took these ranks very seriously and real competitiveness started between us.
我们处于战争状态。莱维特先生把班级组织成了严格的军事等级制度。一些最受欢迎、适应力最强的孩子被选中成为核心内阁成员。其他人是自由警察，有的则是内阁成员的传令兵。莱维特先生变成了莱维特将军。他制作了复杂的墙壁图表，列出了每个学生的等级和职责。我们非常认真地对待这些等级，我们之间开始产生真正的竞争。
OK, takeover tactical. September 24, the flags are put up. 26, demands made to Glenn to wear armbands.
OK，夺权战术。9月24日，旗帜挂起来了。26日，向格伦（Glenn）提出佩戴袖标的要求。
I asked Mr. Levitt to read me his master plan, the timetable of everything that he wanted to happen.
我让莱维特先生给我读他的总计划，也就是他想要发生的一切的时间表。
September 1, freedom police take over the lunchroom supervision. Oh, that was terrific. We demanded that we were going to take that over and we stormed the lunchroom and said, everybody out.
“9月1日，自由警察接管午餐室监督。噢，那太棒了。我们要求接管它，我们冲进午餐室，说：‘所有人出去。’”
The thrill of being in this mob of seventh graders is that you belong to this group. You're part of this thing that you believe so intensely. Everybody looked at us in school and we were somebody. We weren't just lowly seventh graders that nobody ever talks to.
身处这群七年级学生暴民中的快感在于，你属于这个群体。你是这个你如此强烈相信的东西的一部分。学校里的每个人都在看我们，我们成了大人物。我们不再只是没人理睬的低级七年级学生。
On the 3rd, demands made to have to have the matron in the lunch room eliminated, whoever that was. And then on the 5th, we had a victory rally because we had actually won this. We made further demands for freedom.
“在3号，要求消除午餐室的女主管，不论她是谁。然后在5号，我们举行了胜利集会，因为我们实际上赢了。我们进一步提出了自由要求。”
What were we trying to do? That's like the big burning question.
我们当时到底想干什么？这就像是最大的、最紧迫的问题。
That's what's scary. In my recollection, I can't even remember what we were fighting for. I just remember the unity was there and that it was something different. And we were trying to change the situation.
那才是最可怕的。在我的记忆中，我甚至记不起我们在为什么而战。我只记得那种团结感，那是某种与众不同的东西。我们当时正试图改变现状。
Yeah, but what was the situation? To a bunch of 12-year-olds, what was the most disillusioning aspect of being in Connecticut at age 12?
是的，但什么是现状？对于一群12岁的孩子来说，在12岁时身处康涅狄格州，最令人幻灭的是什么？
I know.
我知道。
Then we put flags and emblems everywhere in the school. On the buses, you name it. They were all over the place. And then the demands that the flags be in every room and that all the students-- all of them-- wear armbands. The whole school would have to wear armbands. Not only were we going to just take over the seventh grade, we were going to take over the whole school here.
然后我们在学校到处放旗帜和徽章。在校车上，随便哪儿。到处都是。然后要求旗帜必须出现在每个房间，所有学生——所有人——都要戴袖标。全校都要戴袖标。我们不仅要接管七年级，还要接管整个学校。
There was never a point at which I stepped outside of that and said, what's going on here? I had been signing all sorts of unbelievable manifestos about the things that we demanded that the principal put into place. I used to say that one of the most valuable lessons I learned from it was never to sign anything you don't read. I said that for a long time until I stopped to think about it. And then I realized that at the time, even if I had read that, I would have signed it anyway.
从来没有一个时刻我跳出来说，这到底是怎么回事？我签署了各种难以置信的宣言，要求校长实施。我曾经说，我从中学到的最有价值的一课是永远不要签署任何你没读过的东西。我说了很长一段时间，直到我停下来仔细思考它。然后我意识到，当时即使我读了那些，我也还是会签的。
The next week here, demand for a middle school student to be principal. And my escape and the rally in the planetarium, and the assembly to announce our takeover of the middle school.
“下一周，要求七年级学生担任校长。还有我的逃跑和在天文馆的集会，以及宣布我们接管中学的会议。”
On a humid October Friday, the experiment finally ended. It was morning, and runners for the inner council came around to all the seventh grade classes, Paul Revere-like, with urgent messages and confirmation of the rumors we had already heard. General Levitt's about to be fired. The inner council has been arrested and held in the principal's office. Now is the time for all good seventh graders to come to the aid of their classmates.
在一个潮湿的十月周五，实验终于结束了。那是早上，内阁成员的传令兵们像保罗·里维尔一样，带着紧急信息来到所有七年级教室，确认了我们已经听到的谣言。莱维特将军快要被解雇了。内阁成员被捕并扣留在校长办公室。现在是所有七年级学生来援助同学的时候了。
All over the school, kids who had never failed to turn in a homework assignment or even disobey authority in any way decided to skip their next class and overthrow the school. I don't remember exactly how we all ended up in the planetarium, but in a spectacular display of our underground network and peer bond, it worked. And by the next period change, over 100 kids stood before General Levitt with armbands on, flags and drums poised for battle. He stood before us dressed in his father's World War II officer's coat and he gave us the speech of our little lives.
在学校各处，那些从不没交作业、甚至从不以任何方式违抗权威的孩子，决定逃掉下一节课去推翻学校。我不记得我们是怎么全部聚集到天文馆的，但通过我们地下网络和同伴纽带的壮观展示，它成功了。到下课时间，100多名戴着袖标、手持旗帜和战鼓准备战斗的孩子站在莱维特将军面前。他穿着他父亲二战时的军官外套站在我们面前，给我们做了我们小生命中最精彩的演讲。
I said, your plans to take over the lunch room, the plans to take over the school, they're in danger now, because a lot of people found out. I'm in trouble. They're going to come and get me. And you've got to protect me against them, because if not, then everything is going to go down the drain. And I said, the inner council has been arrested. And I don't know what's going to happen to them. But we can't allow anything to happen to them. And the only way we can do it is if we all stick together, stay together, and you protect me, and then they can't do anything with 100 kids.
“我说，你们接管午餐室的计划，接管学校的计划，现在处于危险之中，因为很多人发现了。我有麻烦了。他们要来抓我了。你们必须保护我，因为如果不这样，那么一切都将付诸东流。内阁成员已经被捕了。我不知道他们会发生什么。但我们不能允许他们发生任何事。唯一的办法是我们所有人聚在一起，留在一起，你们保护我，然后他们就拿100个孩子没办法了。”
General Levitt finished his speech and went into hiding. And we took matters into our own hands.
莱维特将军结束了他的演讲，躲了起来。我们开始自己动手。
We said the chant. We went out running through the mall area. There were other students. People were just looking at us, thinking, what is going on? And I remember heading towards the principal's office, getting in there and hearing crying and screaming. And I remember looking into the office and seeing [? Kathy ?] McDonald hiding underneath the desk.
我们喊了口号。我们跑向商场区域。还有其他学生。人们只是看着我们，心想：这到底是怎么回事？我记得朝着校长办公室走去，进去后听到哭喊和尖叫。我记得往办公室里看，看到凯西·麦克唐纳（Kathy McDonald）躲在桌子底下。
And then we staged a sit in Principal Glenn Anderson's office, his outer office. And he came out and was like, you have got to stop. And we just sat there and ignored him. And you have to understand, for a 12-year-old girl like myself, this was just incredible. I had never done anything against any elder in my life.
然后我们在格伦·安德森（Glenn Anderson）校长的办公室外间举行了静坐。他出来说：“你们必须停止。”我们只是坐在那里无视他。你需要明白，对于像我这样12岁的女孩来说，这真是太不可思议了。我一生中从未对任何长辈做过任何反抗的事。
And then something unexpected happened. Levitt showed up, obviously not arrested. We were shocked. Then he did something even more unexpected. He saw Glenn Anderson, our principal, the man we'd been fighting for weeks, the man who had arrested the inner council, public enemy number one. And Mr. Levitt crossed over and stood next to him. And his body language changed. He deflated from messianic revolutionary to small town social studies teacher. The principal read an announcement over the PA system, saying that this had all been a simulation, an experiment, a hoax.
然后发生了一件出乎意料的事。莱维特出现了，显然没被逮捕。我们惊呆了。然后他做了件更出乎意料的事。他看到了格伦·安德森，我们的校长，那个我们已经对抗了几个星期的人，那个逮捕了内阁成员的人，第一号公敌。莱维特先生走过去，站在他旁边。他的肢体语言改变了。他从救世主般的革命者缩水成了一个小镇的社会研究老师。校长通过广播系统宣布，这一切都只是一次模拟、一个实验、一个骗局。
It was like falling off a cliff.
那种感觉就像从悬崖上掉下来。
I just remember sitting back in my seat thinking, I can't believe I let myself be so controlled by these people, and just feeling so used and so taken advantage of.
我只记得坐在座位上想，我真不敢相信我竟然让自己被这些人控制到这种程度，感到自己被利用和占了便宜。
It was kind of devastating to me that here I'd been tricked or fooled by the very person I was suppose to respect.
对我来说这简直是毁灭性的，我竟然被我本该尊敬的人戏弄或愚弄了。
Then they went on to explain to us that this was a very positive thing, that we'd really learned from this experience, and we can take this with us. But it just didn't matter. Nobody wanted to hear that at that moment.
然后他们继续向我们解释说这是一件非常积极的事情，我们从这次经历中真的学到了很多，我们可以把这些带走。但那根本不重要。那一刻没人想听这些。
For months after the totalitarian experiment ended, parents and school officials argued over it. The local press kept it alive. The school board held public hearings that became like a circus, featuring every local interest group, the back to basic parents, the back to Earth parents, the Christian fundamentalists. In the end, Mr. Levitt was allowed to keep his job and more than two decades later, all the classmates I spoke with said that they were glad it happened to us.
在极权主义实验结束后几个月，家长和学校官员为此争论不休。当地媒体让这件事一直保持热度。校董事会举行了公开听证会，变成了一场马戏团表演，各色利益团体粉墨登场：支持“回归基础”的家长、支持“回归自然”的家长、基督教原教旨主义者。最终，莱维特先生得以保住工作。二十多年后，我采访的所有同学都说，他们很高兴这件事发生在我们身上。
How would I be different had I not gone through that? I think I would probably have taken a longer time to see my own dark side. I'm actually happy that I was able to see it at a young age, when I couldn't do much damage. But I think we all have a dark side. And so the lesson here for me, this is the kid who on every level was a kid who had been well-raised, respectful, worked hard, wanted to please her parents, wasn't rebellious, tried to be a good sister. I was a kid who was what you want all, I think at that point, kids to be. And yet, I was the perfect little fascist. I was the perfect little Nazi. That's what's scary about it, that it can take all of the good potential and harness it for evil without you having any sense at all that you've lost your way.
如果不经历那件事，我会变成什么样？我想我可能需要更长的时间才能看到自己阴暗的一面。我其实很高兴能在年轻的时候看到它，那时我还没法造成什么大破坏。但我认为我们每个人都有阴暗面。对我来说，这就是教训。那个孩子在各方面都是个教养良好、恭敬、努力工作、想取悦父母、不反叛、努力做个好姐姐的孩子。那时的我，是所有家长都希望孩子成为的样子。然而，我却是个完美的法西斯小纳粹。这才是最可怕的地方，它可以利用所有的良好潜能去为邪恶服务，而你完全感觉不到自己已经迷失了方向。
It didn't scar me for life. It didn't traumatize me beyond that first day. I got over it. I bounced back. You move on. And you just try to put it into perspective. And we then moved right away into the study of the rise of fascism in Western Europe. And there's no comparison, obviously, to studying the rise of fascism in Western Europe after having been a fascist.
它没有给我留下终身的伤疤。除了第一天，它并没有给我造成创伤。我克服了它。我恢复过来了。你向前看。你只是试着去正确看待它。我们随即立刻投入了对西欧法西斯主义兴起的研究。在经历过自己成为法西斯之后，再研究西欧法西斯主义的兴起，这显然无法相比。
John Maloney is now a therapist working with teenagers who are in gangs. He says he'd never run a simulation like Mr. Levitt did.
约翰·马洛尼（John Maloney）现在是一位治疗师，专门帮助帮派中的青少年。他说他永远不会像莱维特先生那样进行模拟。
I'd probably worry about how kids are handling it and not saying anything about it. I don't know. Not all of us are as durable as everybody else, you know what I mean? I'd feel responsible until the day that-- I don't know when I could feel that I undid it if it were negative.
我可能会担心孩子们如何处理它，却什么都不说。我不知道。我们并不是所有人都有那么强的承受力，你明白我的意思吗？我会一直感到负有责任，直到——我不知道如果结果是负面的，我什么时候才能觉得我挽回了它。
Many of my classmates wondered what had happened to Mr. Levitt. One of the most surprising discoveries when I had caught up with him was that at the time of the experiment, he was only 22. It was his first job. And of course. Who else but a 22-year-old would try something so brazen? Not long after the simulation, Mr. Levitt quit teaching, went to seminary and into the ministry, which he just recently left. These days, he's remarkably young looking. No gray hair, though a certain energy he used to have has faded. He told me he's lost his sense of mission. He seems unsure of himself. When I asked him if he'd do a simulation like the one he tried on us again, he said, no, probably not.
我的许多同学想知道莱维特先生后来怎么样了。当我找到他时，最惊人的发现之一是，在那个实验的时候，他才22岁。那是他的第一份工作。当然了。除了22岁的人，还有谁会尝试如此大胆的事情？模拟实验不久后，莱维特先生辞去了教职，去了神学院并进入了教会工作，他最近刚离开。这些天，他看起来非常年轻。没有白发，尽管他曾经拥有的一定能量已经消失了。他告诉我他失去了使命感。他对自己似乎缺乏信心。当我问他是否会再次进行他当年对我们尝试的那种模拟时，他说：“不，可能不会了。”
It was tough. It was really hard to do, let me tell you that. It was a lot harder than I thought it was going to be, because I thought I was going to be doing it as a teacher, who had taught everybody a valuable lesson. When I saw your faces and when I told you, I felt I'd let you down, that I had duped you, I had tricked you, I had totally used you in order to teach you a lesson. And I can remember going home and just being up most of the night. And it was very, very difficult.
那很难。那真的很难做到，我告诉你。这比我预想的要难得多，因为我以为我是在以一个老师的身份这样做，给每个人上了一堂宝贵的一课。当我看到你们的脸，当我告诉你们真相时，我觉得我辜负了你们，我欺骗了你们，我戏弄了你们，我彻底地利用了你们，只是为了给你们上一课。我记得回到家，几乎整晚没睡。那真是非常、非常困难。
I am 38 eight years old now. My personal experiment in peer group conformity continues. It comes and goes. And I remember Mr. Levitt's experiment now and then in odd moments. When I see someone preaching to a crowd, I'm suspicious. And the more magnetic the speaker, the more suspicious. The truth is, I loved those three weeks in 1973. I had felt a swell of belonging and then a chill. That is the victory, I suppose.
我现在38岁了。我在同伴群体顺从性方面的个人实验仍在继续。它时断时续。我偶尔会在奇怪的时刻想起莱维特先生的实验。当我看到有人在人群中布道时，我就会起疑心。演讲者越有磁性，我就越怀疑。事实是，我热爱1973年那三个星期。我曾感到一阵归属感，接着是一阵寒意。我想，这就是胜利。
Karen Bernstein is a producer for public television in New York.
凯伦·伯恩斯坦是纽约公共电视台的制片人。
[MUSIC - "ONE TIN SOLDIER (THE LEGEND OF BILLY JACK)," COVEN]
[音乐 - “锡兵（比利·杰克的传奇）”，Coven]
Act Three, The Hissing of Winter Lawns . What happens when a crowd converges over something they strongly believe in for weeks and months in front of television cameras that never go away? To what degree do the cameras change the character of being in a crowd? A few days before Elian Gonzalez was seized by federal authorities, reporter Alix Spiegel went to the lawn of his home where activists camped out 24 hours a day. In the evenings, the crowds would swell and there'd be choreographed protests and prayers for the TV networks. Media savvy, everyone knew the appropriate things to say to reporters. But in other ways, Alix Spiegel reports, they were like any political gathering.
第三幕，《冬日草坪的嘶嘶声》。当一群人因为他们强烈信仰的东西，在电视摄像机从不离去的情况下 converged 数周甚至数月，会发生什么？摄像机在多大程度上改变了置身于人群中的特质？在埃连·冈萨雷斯（Elian Gonzalez）被联邦当局带走前几天，记者阿利克斯·斯皮格尔（Alix Spiegel）来到了他家门前的草坪上，那里有活动人士24小时露营。晚上，人群会增加，会有为电视网络准备的精心编排的抗议和祈祷。媒体精明，每个人都知道对记者该说什么。但正如阿利克斯·斯皮格尔报道的那样，他们在其他方面和其他任何政治集会没什么两样。
When I arrive at 1:00 in the morning, there are about 40 people awake and milling around, swapping stories and guzzling soft drinks like neighbors at a Sunday barbecue. The first person I meet is a man in a lawn chair. He's got a portable CD player in his lap and his earphones on, and he's grooving to some music. His name is Javier and he takes me on a tour.
凌晨1点我到达时，大约有40个人还没睡，在四周转悠，交换故事，像周日烧烤邻居一样狂饮软饮。我遇到的第一个人坐在草坪椅上。他的膝盖上放着便携式CD播放机，戴着耳机，正在伴随音乐律动。他叫哈维尔（Javier），他带着我参观。
It looks like a refugee camp.
这看起来像个难民营。
All the truly committed have the seats in the front. To the right of the police barricades, under a blue tarp strung between street signs, are the hardcore supporters who have been here from the beginning. In a similar place of honor, on the opposite side of the street, the survivors from the Bay of Pigs. And then there are the cheap seats. The street, the sidewalk, the driveways. This is where Javier sleeps. He's been here 10 days. He came, he says, with a sleeping bag, a few changes of clothes, and his CD player. Abandoned his home and job and family to come and protect little Elian.
所有真正坚定的支持者都坐在前排。在警察路障右侧，在一块拉在街道标志牌之间的蓝色防水布下，是那些从一开始就在这里的核心支持者。在街道另一侧的类似荣誉位置，是猪湾入侵的幸存者。还有更廉价的位置。街道、人行道、车道。这是哈维尔睡觉的地方。他在这里待了10天了。他说他带着一个睡袋、几件换洗衣服和他的CD播放机就来了。放弃了他的家、工作和家人，来保护小埃连。
In the morning I see him again. And again, he's got on his earphones and he's grooving to his music. So I ask what he's listening to. And he tells me it's a song by Mr. Phil Collins, which reminds him of little Elian. He says that since he arrived, he's listened to this song well over 70 times. Whenever he's feeling down or overwhelmed by the 24-hour vigil, and that he also likes to play the song for the other supporters on the street. He says that often when he plays the song for the other supporters, their eyes will fill with tears. This makes me curious, so we sit down on the sidewalk and he presses the earphone of his CD player to my microphone and sings along.
早上我又见到他了。他依然戴着耳机，伴随音乐律动。所以我问他在听什么。他告诉我那是菲尔·柯林斯（Phil Collins）先生的一首歌，让他想起小埃连。他说自从他来之后，他听这首歌已经超过70遍了。每当他感到沮丧或被这24小时的守夜活动压得喘不过气时，他也会为街上的其他支持者播放这首歌。他说通常当他为其他人播放这首歌时，他们的眼睛会充满泪水。这让我感到好奇，所以我们在人行道上坐下，他把CD播放机的耳机贴在我的麦克风上，跟着唱了起来。
[SINGING] Now stop your crying, it will be all right. Just take my hand, hold it tight. I will protect you from all around you. I will be here, don't you cry.
[歌唱] 现在停止哭泣，一切都会好起来。只要拉住我的手，紧紧握住。我会保护你免受周围一切的影响。我会在这里，别哭。
A few days ago, Javier was taken to jail for attempting to break down a police barricade. And the other supporters, who had known him less than a week, raised almost $1,000 to bail him out. It's easy to find this kind of ad hoc solidarity here. It's also easy to find sentimentality, melodrama, and paranoia. Several people, I'm told, have made out their wills, expecting to die in front of the TV cameras on Elian's lawn.
几天前，哈维尔因为试图冲破警察路障被带进了监狱。而那些认识他不到一周的支持者，筹集了近1000美元将他保释了出来。在这里找到这种临时团结感很容易。找到多愁善感、情节剧和妄想也很容易。有人告诉我，有几个人已经立下了遗嘱，期待着死在埃连草坪上的电视摄像机前。
Javier tells me that there are dangers all around. Four days before the feds seize Elian, rumors circulate in the crowd that Janet Reno is hiding out in Miami. They say she only pretended to board a plane and fly back to Washington, but in actual fact, landed the plane close by and is now stationed somewhere inside the city limits. There's another rumor that the feds have been practicing stealing little Elian away in a big white van disguised as a plasma unit. They will sedate him, probably with gas, and deliver him to his father, who will take him back to Cuba where he will eventually be killed.
哈维尔告诉我到处都是危险。在联邦调查局带走埃连前四天，人群中传言珍妮特·雷诺（Janet Reno）躲在迈阿密。他们说她只是假装登机飞回华盛顿，但实际上飞机降落在附近，她现在就驻扎在城市范围内的某个地方。还有另一个传言说联邦调查局一直在练习用一辆伪装成等离子血浆车的白色大货车偷走小埃连。他们会用麻醉他，大概是催泪瓦斯，把他交给他的父亲，他父亲会把他带回古巴，最终他会被杀掉。
I hear that Elian will be killed from six different people, people anxious for me to understand why it's so important to be vigilant, even when that means being on guard against one another.
我从六个不同的人那里听说埃连会被杀，他们急于让我理解为什么保持警惕如此重要，即使这意味着要对彼此保持戒心。
You can see when people's eyes are [WHISTLES]. They're not really listening, they're not all there. They can't say the national anthem, they can't say the Cuban anthem. And some people act like they're with us. And when they're saying the anthem, they're not saying it, they're mumbling it.
你可以看出什么时候人们的眼神[哨声]。他们并没有真的在听，他们并不完全在那里。他们不能唱国歌，不能唱古巴国歌。有些人表现得好像和我们在一起。当他们唱国歌时，他们不是在唱，而是在嘟囔。
It's a matter of fact. A couple of days ago we had two of them. They were laughing and they were telling us that they were tourists. As a matter of fact, one of them tells me that he just came a couple of days from Havana and his other friend came from Cleveland, Ohio. And he came to pick him up. And they were going to do the South Beach scene. And they heard about Elian and came over. I said listen, guys. I was born here. My husband is a military man. If it looks like an agent, if it smells like an agent, you guys are an agent. And you look the part.
这是事实。几天前，我们有其中两个人。他们笑着告诉我们他们是游客。事实上，其中一个人告诉我他刚从哈瓦那来几天，他的另一个朋友从俄亥俄州克利夫兰来。他来接他。他们打算去南海滩逛逛。他们听说了埃连的事就过来了。我说：“听着，伙计们。我是在这里出生的。我丈夫是军人。如果它看起来像特工，闻起来像特工，你们就是特工。你们的样子就是那样。”
And he says, look, I've got a driver's license. I said, you really think that we're that ignorant here? These are not just people who got off the boat, for god's sake.
他说：“看，我有驾照。”我说：“你真的认为我们这里的人那么无知吗？这些人可不仅仅是刚下船的人，看在上帝的份上。”
Our conversation is interrupted by a press conference. For some reason, as soon as the cameras begin to roll, Javier pops up and makes his way behind a stripe of yellow police tape, through the private yard of the neighbor directly across the street from Elian's house and into the restricted press area. I follow him and observe, as he crouches behind a cameraman, pulls out a pad of paper and a pen, and starts scribbling notes. He is pretending to be a reporter, using the pen and paper as props, occasionally raising his hand as if he's going to ask a question.
我们的谈话被一场新闻发布会打断了。不知为什么，摄像机一开始转动，哈维尔就跳了出来，穿过一条黄色的警察警戒线，经过埃连家正对面邻居的私人院子，进入了受限的新闻区。我跟着他观察，当他蹲在摄影师身后，拿出一块记事板和一支笔，开始胡乱记笔记。他在假装自己是记者，把笔和记事板当作道具，偶尔举手示意，仿佛要提问。
I'm so busy watching him that it takes a full 10 minutes before I realize that I, myself, am being watched. A Cuban woman with long black hair is spying on me as I spy on Javier. I catch her eye, and she signals for me to come over, which I do. She wants to know exactly what Javier thinks he's doing. So naturally, I ask her why she wants to know.
我太忙于看他，直到过了足足10分钟，我才意识到我本人正在被监视。一个留着黑色长发的古巴妇女正在监视我，就像我在监视哈维尔一样。我与她对视，她示意我过去，我就过去了。她想准确地知道哈维尔认为他在做什么。所以自然地，我问她为什么想知道。
I'm concerned because everyone is being observed as far as any kind of conduct to provoke violence or disorder, because we don't want that. And this individual has done that. And he was taken to jail, and we took him out. We bailed him out with our own money. And now he's out. And he's got a lot of unexplainable and mysterious sources and phone calls.
“我很担心，因为每个人都在被观察，关于任何引起暴力或混乱的行为，因为我们不希望那样。而这个人已经那样做了。他被送进了监狱，是我们把他弄出来的。我们用自己的钱把他保释出来的。现在他出来了。他有很多无法解释的、神秘的来源和电话。”
You're afraid that he's like some kind of plant. And people have been talking about the possibility that he is?
“你担心他是某种卧底？人们一直在谈论他可能是的可能性？”
Yeah, I was called yesterday. In the afternoon I was called to make sure that I just keep an eye on him, that's all. See what he's doing.
“是的，昨天有人打电话给我。下午有人打电话给我，确保我盯紧他，就是这样。看看他在做什么。”
Her name is Rita. She left her baby son with her mother two months ago, and has been sleeping in a lawn chair under a tarp in front of the barricade every night, waiting for the feds to come. She tells me that the people who asked her to keep an eye on Javier are part of an organization. She can't tell me very much about it, not even its name, only that 7,000 people are involved and that they're all good people who don't want to cause any trouble.
她叫丽塔（Rita）。她两个月前把男婴留给了她母亲，每天晚上都睡在路障前防水布下的草坪椅上，等着联邦人员到来。她告诉我，那些要求她盯紧哈维尔的人是一个组织的一部分。她不能告诉我太多，甚至连名字都不能说，只说涉及7000人，他们都是不想惹麻烦的好人。
How can I explain this? We're trying to filter the bad people out. We don't want anybody, especially anybody sent by Castro.
“我怎么解释呢？我们正试图把坏人过滤掉。我们不希望有任何人，特别是卡斯特罗派来的任何人。”
So you think that Javier might be sent by Castro?
“所以你认为哈维尔可能是卡斯特罗派来的？”
That's still under speculation. But yeah, sure. Many people have come here that are sent by Castro.
“这还在猜测中。但是的，当然。很多人来这里都是卡斯特罗派来的。”
As Rita whispers, Javier emerges from the press conference. He's laughing and congratulating himself on his hoax as Rita approaches and casually starts up a conversation. She tells him that she goes to college at Miami Dade.
当丽塔低声耳语时，哈维尔从新闻发布会现场出来了。他笑着为自己的恶作剧感到自豪，这时丽塔走过来，若无其事地开始谈话。她告诉他她是在迈阿密戴德学院上学的。
That's fantastic.
“太棒了。”
I'm studying human behavior. and? I'm very good at it.
“我研究人类行为。而且？我很擅长。”
Because I love kids.
“因为我爱孩子。”
You seem very educated in what you're doing. I really admire that you came here and everything. I can't believe you went to jail for this cause.
“你对你所做的事情看起来非常有修养。我真的很佩服你来这里做的一切。真不敢相信你为了这项事业竟然进了监狱。”
I wasn't interested in going to jail. If that guy hadn't grabbed me, I wouldn't have gone to jail. I was going to cut those two [UNINTELLIGIBLE] chains.
“我对进监狱没兴趣。如果那个家伙没抓住我，我就不会进监狱。我本来打算剪断那两条[听不清]锁链的。”
Why were you going to cut them?
“你为什么要剪断它们？”
It's a long story.
“这是一个漫长的故事。”
Who told you to cut them?
“谁让你剪断它们的？”
I can't tell you. And I can't tell you if somebody did tell me to cut them.
“我不能告诉你。而且我不能告诉你是否真的有人让我剪断它们。”
You can't tell me? Why can't you tell me?
“你不能告诉我？为什么不能告诉我？”
Because everybody is doing what they could for the cause. My job is to cut the chains. That's what I did.
“因为每个人都在为这项事业竭尽所能。我的工作就是剪断锁链。这就是我做的。”
No one that I know-- and I know everyone here-- told you to cut that chain. Was it Jorge?
“我认识的人里——而且我认识这里的每个人——没人让你剪断那条锁链。是豪尔赫（Jorge）吗？”
I'll tell you what, when all this is over, I'll introduce you to him.
“我告诉你吧，当这一切结束时，我会把你介绍给他的。”
That won't helps us, right?
“那对我们没帮助，对吧？”
OK, turn it off for a second?
“好吧，先关掉它好吗？”
I scurry off and mingle with the other supporters while Rita and Javier work it out. The next time I see Rita, she's lying down under her tarp with a cloth over her face, nursing a headache. She looks tired.
我匆忙跑开，混入其他支持者中，同时丽塔和哈维尔在处理这件事。下次见到丽塔时，她正躺在防水布下，脸上盖着一块布，正忍受着头痛。她看起来很累。
Rita, hi. How did it go?
“丽塔，你好。怎么样了？”
It's OK. I'm just going to observe from afar.
“还行。我只是从远处观察。”
What did he say?
“他说了什么？”
He just kept explaining and giving excuses. And he was just too jittery. I don't know. I don't want to judge him.
“他只是不停地解释和找借口。他太紧张了。我不知道。我不想评判他。”
Rita, it turns out, hasn't slept in two days. She's been too busy worrying and wondering when the feds will come.
丽塔，事实证明，已经两天没睡觉了。她一直在担心，想知道联邦人员什么时候会来。
And the rest of America is like, oh, come on, we're just sick of this. Just send the boy home. The boy should be with the father. Of course, but they're not seeing the whole story. They don't want to. They're too busy wondering whether their portfolio is going up or down.
而美国其他地方的人就像是：“噢，得了吧，我们受够了。把男孩送回家吧。男孩应该和父亲在一起。”当然应该，但他们没看到完整的故事。他们不想看。他们太忙于担心他们的资产组合是涨了还是跌了。
The whole story goes something like this. Rita's grandfather was killed by the Castro regime for saying three words, this isn't good. The man who sleeps in the last chair next to hers says he watched his friends and neighbors be machine gunned into the ditch behind his house. The blind woman who stays across the street says she was thrown into a mental institution for dissonant behavior. And it's as if, by saving this one boy, all this history will be redeemed and these people will finally get justice by proxy.
完整的故事大约是这样的。丽塔的祖父因为说了三个字——“这不好”——被卡斯特罗政权杀害了。睡在她旁边那把椅子上的人说，他看着他的朋友和邻居被机枪扫射进他房子后面的沟里。住在街对面的盲人妇女说，她因为异见行为被扔进了精神病院。就好像通过拯救这个男孩，所有这些历史都能得到救赎，这些人最终会通过代理人获得正义。
Look, something mysterious has called me to do this. You have to do this, no matter what. In the past, in the future, you have to do this. Justice has to be served here. And I can not see beyond that. I can not believe that I'm doing this. Remember, I was raised American. I've been here since I was two years old. I should be back with the internet crowd and talking about 'N Sync and all that. That's what I should be doing. But I'm here because I have a calling that's beyond all that superficial ignorance.
“听着，有某种神秘的东西召唤我做这件事。你必须做这个，无论如何。在过去，在未来，你都必须做这个。正义必须在这里得到伸张。我无法超越这一点。我无法相信我竟然在做这个。记住，我是作为美国人长大的。我两岁就到这里了。我本该回到互联网群体，谈论‘超级男孩’（'N Sync）之类的东西。那才是我该做的。但我在这里是因为我有一个超越所有那种肤浅无知的使命。”
So does this feel better to you than anything that you've done before?
“所以这感觉比你以前做过的任何事情都好吗？”
Yes. It makes me feel like I'm alive.
“是的。这让我觉得我活着。”
It's certainly true that there's real anger here, present just under the surface, which erupts with little warning at any suggestion of dissent. I'm standing in the middle of the street watching a group in a semicircle mumble their way through a prayer, when a man standing next to the circle pulls out a sign which communicates his sentiment that Elian belongs with his father in Cuba. And this single act has roughly the same effect as throwing a match into a pool of gasoline. Instantly, a mob rises out of nothing and converges on the man. Men and women are screaming and flailing their arms. And literally, within seconds, the peaceful prayer circle has been transformed into a full-blown human tsunami.
确实，这里存在着真正的愤怒，潜伏在表面之下，只要有一点异议的苗头，就会毫无预警地爆发。我正站在街道中间，看着一个半圆的人群喃喃地进行祈祷，这时站在圆圈旁边的一个人掏出一块标语牌，表达了他的观点，认为埃连应该回到在古巴的父亲身边。这个单一的举动产生的效果，大约等同于把一根火柴扔进汽油池里。瞬间，一群暴民平地而起，向那个人涌去。男人和女人在尖叫，挥舞着手臂。真的，在几秒钟内，平静的祈祷圈就变成了一场十足的人类海啸。
Overweight cameramen stream out of the press area, shouldering heavy equipment and flood the mob with TV lights. There is a lot of jostling and noise, but the circle of people closest to the man keep the rest of the mob from actual violence. Through the chaos, the mob somehow chooses a direction. They move the man organically, almost beautifully, down the street to the police cars at the end of the block where they deliver him, minus the sign plus a couple slaps on the head, to police officers who stuff him in a car and speed away.
超重的摄影师们从新闻区涌出，扛着沉重的设备，用电视灯光照亮了暴民。人群中有很多推搡和噪音，但最靠近那个人的圈子阻止了暴民进行真正的暴力。在混乱中，暴民不知怎么选择了一个方向。他们有机地、甚至美丽地把那个人推到街头尽头的警车旁，在那里，除了那块标语牌，再加上对他头部的几次拍打，把他交给了警察，警察把他塞进车里飞驰而去。
Before the car has cleared the block, the mob begins to disperse. They wander back towards the rest of the crowd and cluster around TV vans parked on the side of the street to watch the video of themselves now being fed to local stations for the 11:00 news. As they watch the footage, a consensus appears to emerge, a consensus which has little to do with what actually happened and everything to do with how they want what actually happened to play in the media. This is the consensus. The mob decides that it was not a mob.
在车子离开街区之前，暴民开始散开。他们游荡回到人群中，聚集在停在街边的电视货车旁，观看他们自己的视频，这些视频现在正被传送到当地电视台播放11点的新闻。当他们观看镜头时，似乎出现了一种共识，一种与实际发生的事情几乎无关，却与他们希望媒体如何报道这件事密切相关的共识。这是共识：暴民决定，那不是暴民。
We're having our peaceful demonstration, and we're having our prayers, and all of the sudden there's a man with a sign that said Elian needs to go home.
“我们正在进行和平示威，我们在祈祷，突然有个男人拿着写着‘埃连需要回家’的标语牌出现。”
And we were trying to take him peacefully out, but he resisted. Nobody hurt him, nobody nothing, we just walked him out.
“我们试图和平地把他带出去，但他反抗。没人伤他，什么也没发生，我们只是把他带出去了。”
Together with all the rest of the people, including the men, we saved him.
“和所有人，包括男人们一起，我们救了他。”
They repeat this line to any media person who asks. This is, after all, a 21st century mob, a media savvy mob. A mob so conditioned that even in the middle of an authentic expression of rage, they're half-conscious of how that rage will play, are both encouraged and constrained by that consciousness. In other words, a mob unable to entirely lose themselves in the act of being a mob.
他们对每一个询问的媒体人员重复这条说辞。这毕竟是21世纪的暴民，精通媒体的暴民。这是一群被塑造得如此彻底的暴民，以至于即使在展现真实的愤怒时，他们也半意识地考虑到这种愤怒在媒体上会产生怎样的效果，受到那种意识的鼓励和约束。换句话说，这是一群无法完全在身为暴民的行为中迷失自我的暴民。
In the fading light, I stand and watch the men watch themselves through the open doors of the TV van. They seem mesmerized, in spite of themselves, by the spectacle of their own unchoreographed fury.
在渐暗的灯光下，我站在那里看着男人们通过电视货车打开的车门看着他们自己。他们似乎被自己那未经编排的狂怒景象所迷住，尽管他们自己也不愿承认。
Alix Spiegel is a reporter in New York City.
阿利克斯·斯皮格尔是纽约市的记者。
Our program was produced today by Alex Blumberg and myself, with Susan Burton, Blue Chevigny, and Julie Snyder. Production help from Todd Bachmann and Eric [? Poverston. ?] Eric leaves our program today for greener and possibly more musical pastures. We wish him the past.
我们今天的节目由亚历克斯·布伦伯格（Alex Blumberg）和我制作，苏珊·伯顿（Susan Burton）、蓝色·切维尼（Blue Chevigny）和朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）参与。制作助理是托德·巴克曼（Todd Bachmann）和埃里克·[？Poverston]。埃里克今天离开我们的节目，去向更环保、可能更有音乐气息的牧场。我们祝他前程似锦。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
You can listen to our programs for free on the internet at our website, where I strongly urge you to go so you can have the thrill of watching that TV ad we started our program with. www.thislife.org. Thanks to Elizabeth Meister, who runs the site. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
您可以在我们的网站上免费收听我们的节目，我强烈建议您去看看，这样您就可以体验一下我们节目开头播放的那则电视广告的快感。www.thislife.org。感谢运营该网站的伊丽莎白·迈斯特（Elizabeth Meister）。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金支持鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who is alert, holding out his hands with his fingers outstretched, saying--
WBEZ的管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）负责，他很机警，张开双手，伸出手指，说着——
Feel the energy.
“感受这种能量。”
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
The city is ours. It is ours, ours, ours.
“这座城市是我们的。它是我们的，我们的，我们的。”
PRI, Public Radio International.
国际公共广播电台（PRI）。